cBS chairman and CEO leslie moonves did
not address his future with the company
in a teleconference with investors but
Moonves predicted long-term success for
CBS in his first public remarks since
multiple women came forward in a New
Yorker article accusing him of sexual
misconduct and a Warner is tracking the
fallout and a good morning good morning
Anthony as Leslie Moonves spoke about
the company's quarterly earnings there
was no mention of the accusations
against him his lawyers apparently
advised him not to discuss the issue and
to some people's surprise
analysts didn't ask it was business as
usual as CBS's top executive arrived for
work ahead of the company's earnings
call as you can see from our results CBS
turned in another very strong quarter
before Leslie Moonves spoke the company
made clear he wouldn't be answering
questions about the allegations against
him in light of pending litigation and
other matters and on the advice of
counsel the scope of today's call and
any questions will be limited to the
quarterly results of the company that
drew some comments from observers not
about those misconduct allegations
I think obviously some people of course
wanted to hear some comments on these
allegations of sexual harassment the CPS
Board has hired two external law firms
to conduct a full investigation of the
allegations in recent press reports
about Moonves CBS News and cultural
issues at all levels of CBS that in
response to a New Yorker article in
which six women alleged sexual
harassment in the article Moonves denied
or said he didn't recall the incidents
he hasn't yet commented on an additional
case in which a woman told police he
sexually assaulted her multiple times in
the 1980s no charges were filed as the
statutes of limitations had run out but
some are speaking to defend Moonves I
was shocked
knowing him as well as I do Suzanne
ficken jur worked for Moonves from 1989
through 2013 when several of the
accusers claimed the incidents occurred
she's one of four former Moonves
assistants who told CBS News they were
not aware of any misconduct I personally
never saw or heard any
thing inappropriate and I worked more
closely with him than probably anyone
else in his entire career a separate law
firm is conducting an independent review
of CBS News which began after the firing
of Charlie Rose over sexual misconduct
allegations that review is expected to
wrap up this month Alex thanks Anna